não há ninguém que está nervosa tatu um
pouco desde meio desestruturada
então as coisas podem não funcionar da
forma como eu previ então né
eu tive sorte de ter ouvido que era ser
mulher traz aos meus 15 anos quando uma
de minhas idas a modelo ela quando ela
falou na sua primeira entrevista a um
programa brasileiro sobre suas
experiências de vida e embora leste
versos falam sobre a vida dela eu daqui
de recife conseguiu estabelecer uma
relação de compreensão e de
identificação com que ela estava falando
leia esta entrevista falava que ser uma
pessoa trans
no nosso caso sem uma mulher trans era
colocar as sandálias contrárias e andar
com elas sandálias todos os dias e e eu
me identifiquei com aquilo e eu fiz
é isso que eu sou a eu fiquei visível
digamos assim
após a minha aprovação aqui na
universidade federal de pernambuco
quando eu escrevo manifestam manifesta é
ilustrado com a minha mãe a senhora
minha sobrancelha não lhe rendeu começa
a chorar nessa fase que estou falando da
minha mãe que eu soube se ana então as
coisas acontece uma forma emocional ea
mãe inclusive evitar que o funcionário
quer dizer aquela muito tá e foi
reconhecido valor muito político contido
nesse manifesto que se chamava meu
manifesto pela igualdade
sobre ser travesti ter sido aprovado em
uma universidade federal
embora seja uma mulher invisível
embora eu tenha conseguido estabelecer
uma relação próxima com a minha reitoria
com a nossa reitoria e ter conseguido o
nome social de travestis de pessoas
trans enquanto regulamentação
essa minha posição ainda um contraste
quando colocada de frente as vidas de
outras pessoas trans pessoa sttrans
estão em uma posição de objeção na nossa
sociedade
nós não convivemos com pessoas trans
nós não conversamos com pessoas trans
elas não estão no nosso círculo família
de amigos e por conta disso anunciaram a
circulação de informação sobre pessoas
trans suficiente que faço aqui que nós
tem influência que eu tive na ao
assistir a lea e que podemos construir
isso infelizmente resulta em transições
hormonais tardias porque infelizmente só
quando a pessoa tem acesso à informação
que ela descobre né
ela tem conhecimento digamos assim do
que ela é
e dentro desse processo de assumir um
ano depois enquanto mulher traz 16 anos
eu me vi bastante segura
eu me vi bastante segura porque eu
percebi que a identidade da mulher trans
ela está atrelada à a aspectos ruins
digamos assim
e nesse processo de está insegura eu
querer que algo me deu um apoio sem
dúvidas eu achei isso o transformismo o
transformismo ele é uma corrente do
feminismo entendendo que o feminismo é
múltiplo são os feminismos entende e o
transformismo ele vejo a voz e escutar
as pessoas trans porque nós não
escutaram as pessoas não falam sobre
pessoas trás e nesse processo eu ter que
me escute eu poder produzir algo falando
sobre minha vida sem dúvida eu estou
trabalhando dentro de do que eu acredito
como uma boa representatividade trans né
e quatro apostas trabalharmos com
uma boa representatividade trans jay z
na televisão
e você viu uma reportagem sobre uma
pessoa trans
você só vai ver certos aspectos
o aspecto da prostituição e
criminalidade e o aspecto das mãos
se você mexe só irão tem notícias de
morte
bom então
e quando falo sobre regras da atividade
fazendo abrir aí quando fala sobre
regras da atividade eu sou justamente
falando sobre humanizar a minha condição
de vida frente a todos vocês e trabalhar
uma boa representatividade é ter por
exemplo uma notícia de uma mulher trans
ou travesti brasileira tendo sido
aprovado em uma universidade federal
lugar aqui pra vocês precisam ter
consciência que nós não estamos entende
e nós não estamos convivendo com vocês
de modo geral e isso é algo que precisa
vir ser humanizado para que vocês tenham
consciência que aquelas pessoas podem
conviver com vocês
e quando falo sobre nós não estamos nós
não estamos nesse espaço é porque vocês
precisam ter consciência que o brasil é
o país que mais mata travestis e
transexuais no mundo tá
nós matamos infelizmente quatro vezes
mais do que o méxico que é o segundo
colocado
então dentro do que eu acredito enquanto
uma transformista
nós estamos falando aqui de uma cultura
enraizada na nossa construção de
indivíduos
nós tratamos travestismo ele quando uma
amiga está muito maquiada nós dizemos
que ela está parecendo um [ __ ] em um
teor pejorativo e isso é naturalizado a
gente fala a gente não questiona entende
e todas essa todas as ações por mais
pequenas que elas pareçam elas dão
ênfase digamos assim nesses percentuais
e dentro dessa cultura né
josé condicionado um ciclo natural eu
percebesse ciclo natural quando eu vi me
vi conversando com amigas mulheres trans
e parecia que nossas experiências de
vida eram compartilhadas experiências
vividas eram essas
nós saímos da escola porque a escola não
representa um lugar de respeito
de acolhimento pelo contrário nós
apanhamos todos os dias nós sofremos não
só violências físicas mas psicológicas e
quando infelizmente procuramos a direção
as professoras para resolver a situação
elas falam mas você tá acontecendo isso
porque você é desse jeito porque você
não muda seu jeito para isso muito pra
isso pode acontecer então se a uma
compatibilização de vítima não se tem um
entendimento que eu enquanto a pessoa
que está apanhando você é reconhecido
como travesti aqui uma violência comigo
essas meninas acabam saindo da escola
porque a escola não representa um lugar
onde nós podemos ter uma boa absorção
habilidade não estamos na escola quando
essas meninas realizam para os pais que
saíram da escola denunciar uma
compreensão uma compaixão que eu
acredito que é o que defende que se
deveria ter de pais para filhos e filhas
e essa sempre essas famílias acabou
colocando essas meninas para fora de
casa e eu coloco essa questão da
aceitação familiar como um ponto
principal para nós sabemos qual vai ser
o futuro daquela menina
se hoje eu estou falando aqui pra vocês
se eu já estou nessa universidade
estudando é porque meus pais me
aceitaram e sem escola sem família
essas meninas vão procurar trabalho mas
que ainda trabalha com a travesti
transexual nas farmácias que vocês não
estão são atendidos alguma travesti já
tem de vocês não
vocês já tiveram aula com alguma
travesti não entendi você já se viram
uma médica travesti no hospital
não entendi nós não estamos no mercado
formal de trabalho e infelizmente parece
que a partir do momento que eu me assumi
um travesti ou transexual vendas dentro
da sociedade automaticamente me é dado
um carimbo que me designação para a
prostituição e na prostituição
nós estamos vulneráveis e por estarmos
vulneráveis e por estarmos vulneráveis a
a maioria de nós morremos
a nossa expectativa de vida é de 3
está há 35 anos enquanto o resto da
população brasileira é de 75
e esse algo alarmante tá isso é algo que
no cotidiano nosso dia a dia a gente
acaba de transformar mais uma coisa
engraçada uma amiga faz 30 anos a gente
falar ouvir a avó
a gente tenta minimizar isso de certa
forma mas continua sendo algo triste
entende e é nesse momento que vocês me
perguntam mas por que vocês estão
jogando essa carga em cima de mim né
e é preciso que aconteceu contextualize
tudo isso para vocês entenderem o
caminho que escolhi que foi o caminho da
educação
eu vejo a educação como sem dúvidas um
fator transformador
eu vejo a educação como quem vai tirar
essas meninas da rua
eu vejo a educação como quem nos vai
ensinar para não termos preconceito com
outras pessoas porque essas pessoas não
estão dentro de um padrão hegemônico que
nós acreditamos que todos devem estar é
o vejo a educação como quem vai criar
mecanismos de apoio mútuo e foi sem
dúvidas disso que hoje me levou está
trilhando o caminho que eu acredito eu
sou maria clara na uso eu tenho 19 anos
eu sou militante há outras feminista eu
sou estudante de pedagogia pela
universidade federal de pernambuco muito
obrigada